[Music]
today's question comes from mike in
texas mike writes my wife and i are in
baby step two and have been able to pay
about four thousand dollars of our debt
in the past three months
however we've hit some bumps along the
way my wife is the sweetest person i
know uh-oh anytime somebody starts a
sentence that way
i have the best wife but
my husband is so great but but my wife
is the sweetest person i know and she
loves buying gifts for people
most recently she bought me a set of
power tools for three hundred dollars
and
that's so nice i do enjoy woodworking i
do not need or want these tools i see
that as a 300 chunk that could have been
put towards credit card debt because
you're right is there a way to politely
decline this gift from my wife and
return it or should i just be grateful
for it and move forward oh jesus whoa
you touch this one dave
um
everybody in this conversation is being
so nice that there's no communication
going on correct
you guys are the softest you pussyfoot
around everything none of you make
anything clear
exactly we're just in the it's like it's
like a saturday night live skit on nice
you know not what you're seeing yes well
she's nice but now i want to be polite i
see i want to be nice and this is these
people are not hillbillies i'm just
saying she buys gifts for other people
to
that that's the way she buys self-esteem
for herself is she pictures herself as a
giving person
so much so that she will take care of
everybody else except for her own
household in order to put on errors that
she is this kind of person
he on the other hand is a wimp and a
coward
and
yes this is a hard conversation there's
no make no bones about it but if you and
your wife have sat down and said here is
a goal that we want to get out of debt
and you're cranking on it three months
four thousand bucks paying off a
thousand twelve hundred dollars a month
on this debt
there's nowhere that anyone in a
situation where the two of you are in
sync on baby step two there's not a
script where she goes and buys 300 worth
of absolutely not i don't know where
that comes from she's either trying to
figure out if this um either it's your
birthday and you left that out she's
trying to figure out if this boundary's
gonna hold she she wants to know if i do
this for you then it's gonna free her to
go back to her away her old ways
this in my house and if let's flip it
around if me and my wife did this and i
bought my wife's up for 300 bucks and
i'm i'm doing that because something
like this has happened over the course
of my marriage
she got upset and she should have been
upset not because i bought our gift
because i've violated the covenant that
we made that here's a plan that we're
going to follow together and then i put
her as the recipient of this making it
her problem not ours anymore and that's
not it's not a cool it's just not cool
right it's manipulative it's
manipulative that's exactly right so the
thing is this um when you when she
walked in with a gift you should have
said no absolutely not we've been we're
in agreement and that would have caught
that would have been a part of a fight
that she had started you weren't causing
the fight at that moment
we were in agreement that we are getting
out of debt you buying me
uh 300 worth of stuff is not part of
that agreement absolutely not period yes
that's not that's not only not nice
it's in violation of you broke your word
to me that's right that's exactly right
you know and but you but this guy never
says anything like that he says oh
thanks i'm going to love these things
and then inside he's sick so i sneak him
back over to home depot and get the
credit right maybe i'll tell her later
yeah that no dude this is like when she
set the box down the counter you're like
what what do we do yeah
wow so tonight sit down and say hey we
have to have a hard conversation
um i'm grateful that you bought me these
things but you and i agreed that we were
going to do this and i'm not grateful
that you bought me these things and
that's right because you violated the
trust that we had put in each other yeah
and so it's more important to me that we
work together and that we keep word to
each other that to get out get rid of
this debt than it is whether i have some
power tools yes or whether you're
generous to me or whether i'm polite to
you and so let's put a list of things
that we want to buy and do with each for
each other and together in the future
and we're going to keep a running list
over the next three years while we get
out of debt let's keep it there or
something but this is just it's just a
violation man and um
yeah there's two
people who are struggling with their own
what they see in the mirror man they're
trying to make it work
you know what i did this too i i hadn't
even thought about it you said you've
done this but i mean i've been married
40 years so i've had lots of
opportunities to do crap wrong
so well i've done this a bunch dave i do
because sharon is a tight wad she does
not like to spend money yeah but her
nature isn't until she's ready and it's
something but i mean most the time
most the time her nature she's a saver
and i'm a spender and i'm also a
one of my love languages is just giving
generosity and so
when we were too broke to do it
i would on her birthday or on an
anniversary buy her a dozen red roses
which is expensive
i mean i don't even know what that costs
now i still do it but it costs a lot
now it's crazy
but uh even then it was like you know
whatever i spent a hundred bucks let's
say well hundreds of million dollars
you're broke right hundred dollars yeah
and
you know where are those flowers in a
month exactly they're in the trash
you know and to her
the uh the sentiment
did not keep up with the stupidity
that's right and so she was more
concerned about the stupidity than she
was the sentiment and it took her
a decade later from that to actually
accept flowers when we can afford them
and enjoy them
but now she's you know now she actually
can enjoy them so she got 40 roses on
her 40th
right which was a lot too but now i can
afford to throw them away in a month and
so now she's not it's not stupid anymore
but i back then i violated the same
thing this woman did so this is the
ramsay show